bravo pour ton pour moi c'est là qu'en
fait ce coluche après ce que je suis
papa de plus beau plusieurs sur mon bon
qu'on va laisser pas sortir 10 pour
comme ça mon grand ami pierre françois
ont chanté asap
on chante et on sait très très belle ça
c'est moche on aurait pu partager
alors l'intérêt tout laideur pas
partager le même lit
moi je me suis battu pour avoir une vie
merveilleuse c'est tres parfois de pas
pouvoir le partager avec un homme
condamné et qui tout ça
l'autre soir en boîte je n'ai jamais vu
comme ça tu étais tellement vivant parce
qu'il est gravé dans ma mémoire
as tu penses tu parles tu me regardes tu
penses à autre chose
mais oui juliette il s'est mis ce soit
et attaquer pas annoncé mais pour
l'éternité
c'est pour les beaux lots sur twitter
et marié
toute façon seul tabou c'est l'homme
marié
je sais pas ce qui me fait le plus peur
c'est au revoir ja m
aucune histoire ne s'arrête jamais
il faut pas qu'elle commence